we do a little face mash it's some
teammates
uh from doing pants that is a weird
style that's me and luke there you go
he's one for one
i don't really see you i mean first off
what can we fix the mouth there what the
heck is going on there
my god what a year it's been last year
we had him in person this year nobody's
in person
but here he is christian mccaffrey the
best running back in the national
football league joining us on the
program christian how are you pal
i'm doing well i appreciate you guys
having me on
well we appreciate you making time for
us we know you're in high demand
uh carolina panthers great well i don't
want to say great season obviously wins
losses but better than a lot of people
have expected matt rule came in and
really took things over
give me your impression of matt rule as
a coach and and where the offense
has been and where it may be heading
yeah i think uh coach rule is awesome i
think uh from from day one he set the
tempo and the standard of what he wants
the the panthers organization to be and
um
i think when you had a year where you
know you have such a young team
there's no otas and uh you know you you
kind of have a lot of guys you know me
included who
you know are injured and not playing um
his ability to maintain that standard
and to maintain
focus uh was awesome for a first year
coach and i know he doesn't look at
himself as a
first year nfl coach because uh of the
success he's had but
um it was encouraging just kind of
taking myself out of
out of play for a little bit and
watching from the outside to see
the growth of our team the growth of our
young guys and have young guys step
up and you know not only that but get
better as the season goes on i think
it's a testament to
to coach rule and staff of the
development that that i got to see uh
just being able to watch
um you know obviously you don't want to
watch but uh being able to see guys like
jeremy chen get better all year
guys like derek brown get better all
year and and to see the hunger that
that you know even when we knew we
weren't going to the playoffs uh you
know we had guys who never quit i think
that's the sign of a
of a good team when your vets and when
you're when your young guys are
are there for the same reasons and i
think the sign of a true competitor is
looking for a positive
in every situation and it sounds like
you really embraced that opportunity
to study the game from a different
perspective how helpful will that be to
you
when it's time to play again having the
opportunity to take a step back
and just kind of absorb and study
yeah i think it'll be really helpful uh
you know obviously it was tough you know
especially early on
um and and the hard part was kind of one
after another you know i'm a guy who
loves playing
every snap of the game and uh you know
never miss the game until this year and
it was one of those things that
you know when it rains it pours so uh
for me
um you know i i had to quickly learn to
to be patient and to find
positives through negative situations
and uh being able to watch
especially in game i think is when i
learned the most being able to see what
the coaches are thinking
what guys respond to best you know as a
leader moving forward how i can grow in
that
in that realm of the game and uh you
know understanding
just the flow of the game in general um
is something that that i think i
i took and i've never gotten to do so um
you know i hope that that you know and i
think also it made me a lot
hungrier so to say you know i think it
took it took me uh
out of out of my realm for a while to
understand how much i
i love this game you know you kind of
get that seven-year-old football love
back
uh you know when it's taken from you so
you know i think and ultimately this is
something that might add another three
four years to my career
so uh you know i i definitely view it as
you know although negative in the moment
is it will be a positive in the long run
yeah i hear you there that's the great
way to look at it yeah you avoided a lot
of car crashes this year so you'll be
fresh for a few more years maybe because
of it
but i do want to talk about like just
because people hear
high ankle sprain and then they see they
go what's the big deal and then you're
this top level specimen and they're like
why what's taking them so long like tell
people a little bit like
the struggles of dealing with the high
ankle sprain and what it does to you at
the running back position
yeah i think to start uh you know the
term high ankle sprain
can mean a hundred different things
right yeah everyone wants to be a doctor
when they find out about an injury
obviously i think i think it doesn't
take you know me
saying this that for people to
understand that sometimes it's not
always just what's out there
there's there's a lot more going on and
it might be a high ankle sprain it also
might be a couple other things that are
wrong with it but
that's just kind of what you say to the
media yeah
transparent that's probably with every
guy's injury in the league
um so you know i i i wanted to play
uh every game but but physically uh
wasn't
couldn't and and that's something for me
that was hard uh when your mind's in one
place and your body's in another
um so you know i came back in the chiefs
game and
my ankle was still a little messed up
you know i had to tape it up a certain
way but
at the end of the day you know i i was
good enough to play
and so i played and and you know
unfortunately the last series of the
game i
separate my shoulder and that's you know
it's not it's not
what was the plan you know it wasn't the
plan for me and one
plan for you know coach rule and coach
brady and
all of my teammates but sometimes that's
the way the game goes you know
you know you got guys who have you know
structural injuries throughout this
whole year you know i've seen
you know aaron rodgers had to miss a
season he got quarterbacks left and
right that missed seasons
uh you know and and at every position uh
and this just wasn't
a year that that went to plan so um
sometimes that's just the way it goes
but but obviously a struggle for me
uh all year but something that i can i
can learn from and
i think it'll make me better in the long
run yeah i mean i i think it will too
and at least you got the right attitude
man
i mean i know it was hard watching some
of these running backs i want you to
break down three of them for me just the
first thought that comes to your head
derek henry dalvin cook alvin kamara
like what jumps out about those three
guys that you'd like to have of their
game and put it in your game
oh i mean i can't there's a hundred
different time and all throughout the
day i wish i was six
[Laughter]
four
my brothers are taller than me so then i
could you know i could have that on them
um no but i think when you look at derek
henry's game
um to be able to do what he does at such
a high level and
you know obviously you see the big play
highlights but i love watching him
uh you know he has some of the best two
three yard runs in the game where he's
breaking tackles in the backfield stiff
farming guys and
you see the highlights but those to me
are the ones that that matter and keep
your offense
uh efficient and you know his obviously
he's tall but his ability to fall
forward and
uh not lose yards is something that
makes him such a great back and keeps
him in the you know efficiency
realm with dalvin cook you know ever
since i
watched him in high school and obviously
at florida state but his explosion and
his ability to
uh take you know plays it might be four
or five yards and make him into 60 yard
touchdown runs
um you know he has everything you want
he's fast he's physical he's quick
he's great balance and i think with
kamara you know he's a guy obviously in
the division that i've been able to
watch
uh watch a lot and you know for me
um you know selfishly i try to watch him
and take a lot of his game and put it in
the minors different things that he does
that
uh you know i try to do or i'll try to
rep in training and
um just a fun guy to watch you know i
think uh
anytime he has the ball in his hands no
matter what it looks like
uh you're kind of on the on the edge of
your seat waiting for something to
happen because he has that ability so
all three guys different backs but i
think that's what makes honestly the
running back position so special is
um there's so many different shapes and
sizes and abilities
uh and it makes a coordinator's job fun
of being able to find ways to get them
the ball in the best situation
your dad ed was a great receiver you're
a great running back
will you steer your own kids away from
the running back position with all the
physicalities chris says the car crashes
that the position entails
now uh you know i think for me i started
playing running back when i was seven my
whole life i've been a running back
because i wanted the ball you know back
then
yeah you know you're seven the helmets
don't even fit guys aren't throwing the
ball very far so they're handing it off
and i wanted the ball so
um i think it's you know the most fun
position i think it's
uh too there's such a creative aspect to
it you know
you have to it's a it's like an art form
because you're it's never the same you
know the whole is never the same
the route is never the same it's all
reaction and eyes and using
your ability to to take what you see and
make the most of it and i think that's
uh
that's such a you know i mean i don't
get artsy but it is such a beautiful
thing when
when that happens because you know it's
it's truly a flow form
you know you like i said it's not just
get the ball and cut left
there's so many moving parts that are
happening in front of you and
being able to take what you see and
react at
minuscule seconds is is uh such a cool
thing so
you know i i definitely uh i definitely
think it's it's one of the best
positions in football
yeah i i hear that now i got to ask you
because
you got to see both teams this year you
know the super bowl teams
chiefs bucks like just you know
assessment
of both defenses and what stood out to
you about them
yeah playing against tampa twice a year
um
you know for the last few years and just
that team in general i think what you
see in their defenses
is obviously they have you know first
rounders left and right
and guys who can play but um they play
well together
and and they flow to the ball and i
think when you look at them up front
um they demand so much and and so you
know it allows their their linebackers
to play freely and make plays and
they have you know two of the best
linebackers in the league on that team
uh then they have a great secondary um
who flies to the ball too
and they play good team defense you know
they answer turnovers with turnovers
they
answer stops when when their offense
gets gets a touchdown
and you know those are the things that
you see in teams specifically defenses
that
you know end up help winning games and i
think the same is for the chiefs
um you know if pat mahomes on the
offense scores
you know they take pride in getting
stops and um you know
their defenses aren't perfect but i
think that's the that's the
the difference between winning and
losing teams is playing great team
football and
and the defense helping the offense out
and the offense helping the defense out
um and i think both teams obviously have
done that really well throughout the
year
christians here today on behalf of
ascent protein tell us about it and
specifically can it help
a broken down middle-aged man like me
look like you
absolutely i think uh you know obviously
one of the one of the biggest aspects of
my life being an athlete but also for
anyone so i
i think you'd fit well for sure um but
now it's uh you know putting
putting clean and uh you know
non-artificial
nutrition and you know into my body is
something that that i found helps and
works so
uh when it comes to recovery when it
comes to training i think
having no artificial ingredients no
artificial sugars and knowing that
what i'm putting in my body is helping
me for my muscle recovery is important
hey christian great stuff as always good
luck to you good luck to the panthers
and we look forward to talking to you
again real soon
appreciate it guys thanks for having me
on the man christian good luck
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports